Okay, we're going to go back to our editor and add an
extra little feature here. Okay, so we're got our first input, type
equals text. I'm going to add a new input that we may not
have dealt with before called type equals hidden. And this is a
sneaky way of including values when you submit your form that
the user can't actually see. Sometimes when you submit a form you
actually want to have more information then what the user's just given
you. That's what type hidden is for. I'm going to give it name,
food and I'm going to give it value X. Okay,
back to the browser. I've refreshed our browser and
reloaded that new page. Now, I'm going to enter in
steak here again. And time for another quick quiz. What
happens when I click add here? What happens when
I submit the form, that has a hidden input
in it already? Do we see one value in
the URL with what we just submitted? Do we see
two values in the URL? The one we just submitted and the
hard coded value. In this case, the hard coded value, what I
mean by that is. The word eggs that we put in that
hidden input that was in our code. Or does the browser error?